special firing the kid Brian did not die
I see you guys on social media asked me
if Brian died he did not his friend is
actually very sick with a rare brain
cancer so he's doing a fundraiser in New
York all this week helping raise money
for his buddy if you're listening to us
this is Wednesday about 1213 afternoon
Pacific time in Los Angeles Brian's in
New York tonight he's at Gotham comedy
club with dove Davidoff also a good
buddy of ours doing a fundraiser for his
friend who you know I think they give
them a three to six months to live so
Brian decided to stay out there which is
understandable and I'm driving the ship
so I need some I needed a co-host man
and I sent out the bat-signal and the
golden pony answer yeah our boy Tony
Hinchcliffe is in the house this is an
honor and a pleasure to the kid I know
man life is good
touring doing stand-up having fun
kicking butt
we were in a New York yep was just in
New York on Sunday we did an episode of
Kel Tony live for the first time in New
York after doing the show for four years
in LA and other places and was sold out
it was awesome the fans were animals did
you go there just to do a kill totally
up just for that we flew in from
Jacksonville that day and did a show at
2:30 p.m. and had the rest of the night
off enjoyed skank fest those guys put on
a real festival comedians do we got to
[ __ ] do a festival I'm so doing you
guys swear on that you can swear we got
it I swear all the time we have to put
on our own fest agree that day obsessed
they I was supposed to be part of it a
big J reached out to my team and just I
was so busy New York and Dubai I love
when other comics when if they invite me
to accessible and I feel like so exactly
cool it's the cool I feel like part of
the club what's that supposed to be been
to so far I went to the Austin moon
tower tower yeah and then I got invited
to the Montreal Comedy Festival I
supposed to go this show sold out my
schedule does allow me to do it so Brian
still better doing a stand-up but those
are 200 and then I did a Wild West
Comedy Festival oh that's a Louisville
moon tower and Wild West or two of my
favorites you like the good ones I see
what your montreal does a big
they do a big one they do a big one
really it's definitely not the most fun
is it got the most people and everybody
all the young all the kids are like I
can't believe we made it to the biggest
Comedy Festival but like at the end of
the day it's about you know weather and
fun and the atmosphere you're there your
friends and you know you want it to feel
like Texas so you want to feel like
Nashville the Wild West Comedy Festival
also because all of a sudden you walk
out the door and it's rock and roll
everywhere like yeah food does that I
always say Nashville's like Vegas
without any of the negatives it's like
just awesome I love a trip from
Nashville people asking me Tony you go
everyw what's your favorite Nashville
Nashville in Austin yeah I love both of
them yep
so tell me social is interesting because
for a guy like me like that moon tower
so far the kids off see the cell they
want fun kids it's going to sell out
right away so we go there and then they
go you know Bren wants to stand up too
so then why you have traded spot so in
moon town I'd like six spot which for a
guy like means ridiculously I felt like
an actual comic yeah Brian's always
doing this thing and then in Montreal
which I have to cancel because I'm in
Toronto and for the big brown breakdown
life there like I would find kid and
then when you get there try the hustle
find spots like dude you I'm there for a
day like it's it's tough gig to do it's
fun now they are fun hanging out with
comedians it's yeah it depends yeah it's
a weird it's a different vibe different
vibe but like the hardest I've ever
laughed is the funniest I've ever had is
like after the comi store we'll go get
some need it's like D'Elia Brian yeah
Brogan we're just chilling there and I
dude I've never laughed so hard in my
life
that's like that all about the Hang is
what it's about and that's like you know
where a lot of the inspiration comes
from item you know it's you know what's
funny about you when you're hanging with
your comedian friends and you make them
laugh if that makes sense like sometimes
the best writing is accidentally done in
those diners in the middle of the night
sure like whoa I just said that and if
that made these four that make sense
geniuses know their own right in their
own way laughs and that's a natural
thought that belongs to
you know what I mean original exactly
that nobody else can even have because
it's your perspective on something than
that all of a sudden you know being a
comedy writer I feel like it's not just
about it's not at all about sitting at a
desk but the blank sheet of paper and
trying to figure out it's about being
aware enough to notice when that stuff
happens like well that's one if you got
more inches right right it's almost like
the bait is always in the ocean you know
how like fishermen here like leave their
poles yeah
hang in and sometimes you get a tug over
there and you just got to notice that
when it happens you're only as good as
noticing you know that the bobber went
down yeah weird and now it's all that's
really that's really makin like a lot
year a lot of Caminos like they say Jay
Seinfeld still this day wakes up he's
doing two hours in more two hours room
or and I'm like I wake up and I would
try and do that cuz I try to mimic these
guys routines yeah my god like I need
some sort of inspiration like went to
Australia and the experiences I had
there like that helped form stuff I
found stuff being on stage or the way
people reacted and stuff like that
making adjustments and you know it's
just like a fight that stand-up is if
you look at it the right way because
it's you know you're making adjustments
to your opponent if you treat the
audience is like a you know like you're
trying to find who that worked yeah okay
so a straight left jab works on the guy
so pop pop a wait and then set reset
that up and set that up properly and
then they're going to think that this is
soap if you make adjustments and we
always reformat my set like I know a lot
of comedians like have a set set and
that's a fun you know that I'm not
saying there's any right or wrong way to
do it but if you have too much of a plan
then you're sort of just like infighting
again if your stuff your people and
implants not working but if you
sometimes stick in the game plan works
but it you got to make the adjustments
if you feel it yeah and you set them up
and you make them think that you know
they have you figured out because it's
all elements of surprise I would have
both things again
I mean you you've seen so many comedians
I mean also you being a basic coming up
through the Comedy Store then with the
kill Tony show I mean so I mean you also
have your black belt in comedy can you
tell right away if someone's gonna yeah
right away right away for those you know
none most you should buy an iron kill
Tony it's a ridiculous amount
show but you have comics come up and
they have one minute of material yeah
well they have one minute of stage time
they have a chance they could be in the
moment they could do material it could
be a crazy person it just wants to try
stand-up every time people you know it's
on line we had some crazy even the one
that leaves in the one we did in New
York City on Sunday it was crazy because
there was until the last person in which
I literally said no crazy people this
episode everybody was coming to kill
like it was like Tonight Show sets every
single program like how long have you
been doing Stan about 12 years 8 years
10 years 7 years 6 years these people
were all which is which which made me so
happy because does it does it is it the
best thing for the format of a show not
necessarily it's a filler the show goes
good it is good and the most important
thing is it's showing that like whoa
these New York comedians respect kill
Tony so much that there's no like I'm
too big for that show if I'm gonna get a
little bit of a break I'm going to get a
little bit of a following Jean I'm going
to shine and that's really cool that was
very you know just like I said it just
happened on Sunday so it's still sort of
like whoa I've got we the show has
gotten to the point to where it's legit
it's an honor to sort of hell yeah it's
really awesome to me and did so there
was a crazy dude last one yeah the last
one I'm literally like man the only
thing I miss about LA is you know we
just have the you know sign-up sheet on
the sidewalk like crazy people can sign
up here it seems like you know they sent
an email blast all the top comedians in
the city
I miss my crazy people let's all keep
our fingers crossed I'm gonna go to the
bucket one more time I pull the name out
Doyle something and he comes up the
first thing you see as he's approaching
the stage this is black t-shirt but the
question marks on it made of green like
pool table felt he made it himself like
a rigid surface didn't cut to the hole
and all you say crazy go to the panel
just high-fiving each other like we did
and we ran what would be magically he
was totally crazy we ended the episode
by lighting is ugly handmade shirt on
fire in the bucket we use the other
comedians names as kindling and how it
goes crazy without
you you do the show with your boy
Jeremiah yeah
really all of you guys know this kid but
Jeremiah he had to be Kyle I'm like I
want it I don't want to be able to
cocaine party with the kids and as far
as comedy goes young really he is the
truth he's coming I've been saying I
said it last week for the first time - I
was talking with Jeff Ross like oh I
don't know what Will Ferrell was like
right before his first thing I don't
know what Jim Carrey was like I'm right
before his living color
I don't but he's there he's about to go
boom I feel like you feel it too if you
pay attention Oh totally totally I work
with him every week for an hour and a
half on kill Tony and he pushes me to
the limit because he kills so hard that
now I have to it's like I don't want to
seem like a guy that just has a killer
cast yeah I got a I got up my game and
that up his and it just makes it so
powerful do didn't he'd insult me by
sliding him yeah and about that
we'll try fighting him yeah he looks
harmless you look him up drew Maya
Watkins I'm most harmless nicest guy
[ __ ] with try fighting Germans got like
girly blonde hair he's just an innocent
little dude you got a good guy who
played like the harp or something in the
background of a movie that jacquees
angelic look at us sweet yeah the [ __ ]
was the mess with him it's unbelievable
what a sweet guy you don't look at him
go mr. studio girl like you could be
better than my girl you can be best
friends my girl Jim I don't know fret I
mean absolutely look at them I'll let
them I'll let them cut along the couch
with her I love do what everyone
everyone watches have sex yeah naked
where to the future come from what the
[ __ ] is that
that did have no justice oh okay that's
I don't know here's open wide oh oh yeah
that glamour shot no just room but if I
love this guys straight coming straight
from a new home alone audition let's try
out for [ __ ] home improvement all the
kids are so precise
homo improvement these are my you're
getting wrote this row it or yeah a we
are loving you mad but that that
glamorous shot [ __ ] the whole thing on
me Jeremiah if you could add a couple
more logos and credits to the top of
your website I don't think we think
you're legitimate enough don't let this
word-of-mouth stuff work for you uh
people seeing the The Laugh Factory logo
that's what's going to yeah so glad you
AG shoe Oh your mama your mama business
that's where you got that that's the
knit hat one that says J Juma I don't
know if you're on tinder now that's
definitely shut you should use your body
okay put on tinder and there we just add
a few cats to make it for three be good
Jeremiah's come in with me I'm doing the
biggest tour of my life in August and I
text you right when you pass out with
holy [ __ ] congrats on the tour and
that's who I'm taking Jeremiah no kids
up for 25 minutes before every show
somewhere around there maybe thirty who
knows what we're going to do but we have
these rock band used to ourselves and
I'm running my new hour fifteen for my
next special that I'm going to do soon
and he's it's an honor to get to take
him I'm not plugging my dates I'm
plugging him still word it's an honor to
get to take him you know what I mean
like um he opens rays and you coming up
and you are all I mean that's I've taken
like gee you know that I'm doing a
little toy nothing to the magnitude that
you I looked at your dates like u P
Diddy I've never done anything like it
Monster Energy Drink hit up my agents
and like we'd like to work with Tony
Hinchcliffe and I'm like what do you
mean mom what kind of knockoff Monster
energy drink once them though I know
actually yeah they're like no the actual
month I'm like the logo that's in the
middle of the octagon monster like the
logo that's part of like extreme cool
stuff and they um they're like yeah I'm
like okay that's another comedian still
they still just get to do what I do I
would like go out and I try to end like
you do yeah right just where I am shirt
all the time yeah I have to I come out
on a skateboard drinking that's pretty
much you just totally sell out cuz
monster world is you know Tony doesn't
even do jokes and all of his punch lines
is just monster energy drink am I
right but if I'll just complete plug
just ruin your career yeah but you're
all over me as soon as I saw us like who
the [ __ ] is you never done anything like
this is nothing something like this and
the thing that makes it really surreal
is like for example one of the dates is
Portland Oregon at the Aladdin theater
and well added me to that's the first
theater I ever did opening up for
Jeffrey Ross and I think 2011 2010 it
was you know really big deal to me to be
doing that and now it's my night
so when I can already picture I remember
that theater the stained glass windows
up guys it's like a cathedral I'll never
forget it and when I saw that on the
schedule like um I've done the helium's
they're a bunch of title of Portland you
know Marc Grossman is the man and all
that but to think that I'm now I'm doing
that thing that started the whole
theater thing for me nuts
it's do you document do you have a like
an photographer in the city document
um I should I definitely should I see
comedians will do enough a Chris D'Elia
about this the other day Rogen's kind of
started to it to me like whatever city I
come into I'm like hey I need
photographer just because I want a
document especially when I'm doing early
on I did this in the UFC I was one of
the only guy doing the assailant why
don't you take pictures I called my boy
Eric Williams like once you document my
training camp behind the scenes
everything because I want that otherwise
I mean again it's part of my bit ctk
kick in any day we I might not remember
[ __ ] I want my kid to be able to go
through like goddamn we get dad man
right this is not yeah otherwise it gets
lost in the ether like it's tough man if
you don't have someone doing and
document and just do you know I'm saying
what you're doing and for social media
it makes it look so much more
professional like you're already a big
[ __ ] deal you're swish on Netflix you
just wanna shoot that [ __ ] it's all
about marketing you know one thing that
I have done is I'll go to a city this
always happens in Salt Lake City have
you been there yet I'm going there oh
well then here's a little gift from me
to you my Foreman's anal yes that's I
don't know what that means my few words
they're more mundane topside
I end up every time I've gone there on
the Friday night I end up trying to find
a way to record my two shows Saturday
like the live video record really and it
always ends up being it ended up doing
it again being my protocol for my next
special the last time I was there I
taped my Saturday sets and I took that
hour and was like this is what I'm going
to make my first special off of that was
about three years ago and this past time
I went there and not even planning it on
the Friday night I ended up hitting up
the same guy Trevor in Salt Lake City I
found it you know what I mean found it a
mother messages exactly and I'm like hey
can we do this again we did it again you
got an hour 16 minutes on the first set
Saturday which was my favorite one and
all of a sudden there you go things they
do that so you film that hour
ready to go in I do with that tape what
would I do with that tape is I show it
to my agents and managers and I go
congratulations you guys are still
repping a bad mother here you go enjoy
you're the first to see it raw footage
of the material on the way and what kind
of it's going to look this is what I've
been working on well you guys have been
in your offices you know I need ya
lookin checks yeah I'm grinding yeah and
they know that I have a knack for
producing a lot of my stuff myself and I
do just get ideas your last one the one
shot yeah I love that man thanks man
I like it I text you that I love it
because again with calmly just like
anything else if everyone's doing the
same thing how are you gonna stick out
right what like Neal Brennan the three
mics yeah [ __ ] love brilliant yeah
you know three mics up with yours with
the one shot was so different unique set
the ISO so at this huge theater well
what's really cool is I ended up getting
finding a director the guy that made a
Ari's double Netflix special that's
coming out yes in a few weeks
ended up working with him on something
he ended up we we had fun that day
working on this little tiny comedy
central snapchat thing and but something
I did stood out to him or whatever and
he went and did his research the next
day sent this cool you know storyboard
about how he wants to make this next one
and how we can really up the production
value while maintaining that same
type of super connective texture as what
I did when I really threw that - I
really like you know I really directed
that thing the original one while doing
stand-up I you know in the pre thing I'm
literally like slow you got to go slower
you got a you know this that and out and
I mean it was not easy is it is that
because you're a control freak or you
know what exactly what you want I knew
exactly what I wanted yeah was where no
one else can get it right and right they
don't know what how I picture it but
yeah exactly it's not a control freak
it's totally like a everybody's going to
be happy if the people like it more so
yeah I got a vision right
yeah if everything else is my bit I feel
like that's what that that is an
interesting thing that you just brought
up though is like I feel like maybe
comedians should control a little more
you know like it's like if you're
putting in the writing you're putting in
the performing you're you're refining it
you're making adjustments and then all
of a sudden it's like they did capture
this yes some guys you didn't the guys
like alright / - it just like everything
I see oh yeah I guess at and I mean this
is your baby and you're the creative one
you want these angles or this in the
background or this yeah weird to me yeah
it's what I mean I lose this game by
watch specials on my time you can tell
they don't have that connection right
and in minds a little bit gritty and
even a little bit like pinky and shaky
at times I like it I do it's raw he
makes it feel like goof did the camera
guy just half trip yeah he did I saw yes
of a corner my eye while I was doing
that joke on the other Friday I hope
that didn't fire yeah and I have to go
here to go back and like readjust the
director had to go in and like six you
know what I mean it's all straight be
speaking a homeboy was all right so I
did this is not happening I'm County
Central I had no idea the drama go down
with re a no idea I get to set I'm all
you didn't what oh sorry I was like if
they're all bomb in the green or with
other comedians and I don't I don't know
any of their great to me but they're
like over here and I'm over here like
that's not Meru looks like you wrote
into Lee alright so I'm like I feel like
the weird kid in school right now
and so do I go where's Arya
ah there's silence yeah I had no idea at
the time I'm all just I just want to
thank you for giving me this opportunity
does anyone at wait wait wait and then
Justin a gene comes in you guys I talk
to you for a second like javis gonna I
didn't oh my god
yeah this is information I could have
used yesterday I man can't believe you
made it all the way in there without
knowing no clue no clue no clue and then
I call Rogan cuz I'm like dude you know
doing content so big deal for me and I
ended up crying on stage which is weird
I got choked up choked up I'm kidding me
no get outdoors ha ha ha was it a Thai
mission with a Comedy Central in 2001
like I mean that's when it would have
been like a dream there's more people
watching you right now on this show then
there are watching alright alright what
are you comedies I try a vitamin by the
way let's just take it easy
I thought gummy central via Dave
Chappelle showcase you know Brian I just
wanna thank you for inviting me on the
spider in the kid is the thing I've
always wanted to do is be the co-host I
was a guest before and I just always
thought that maybe if I just wondering
it maybe one day if one of Brian Callens
friends get sick enough maybe I can be
sitting in one of those rich chicken I'd
like a side of it I think it's gonna cut
from you crying to some like I've fallen
on I can't get up commercial how many
specials look your bus was dead life
earlier clean save you a comic gentle
the plumbers these days that big guy
crying out this yeah no no no tears I
choked up don't know what's up with the
big tough crying guy on confidence I'm
sorry wait on essentials really
unsounded me it's like you think [ __ ]
up there now trying to be telling dick
jokes behind what has happened is
getting rear naked choke tup up their
pain traumas a [ __ ] man that's right I
didn't think that's longing
god no idea that your life and the road
like you kidding me laughter he didn't
we have like a two-hour conversation
that the comes from the particle and I
was like oh my god he's like yeah like
I'm doing it now it's like I had no idea
about it sorry upset I did it no no man
that stuff's crazy what happened with
that I don't even know if Ari is talking
about it but I will say that comes outta
matically it's gonna be some interesting
stuff yeah man oh so good I mean it's it
tough it's an interesting thing now you
just gotta take care of yourself and you
gotta get out there and the formats
changing the dynamic has changed simply
similar to your point earlier you know
how you're talking about how you know
comedy and mixed martial arts same thing
makes martial arts you know I tell these
guys you should have your own publicist
you know your manager be on the ball you
step your merchandise you should be
telling your story not waiting for the
Big Show to tell her story or come
around like oh yeah that girl
yeah she's interesting now let's talk
about her we can't wait for that same
thing with comedy like man let's be
honest if you're really not on Netflix
you're not in that shuffle especially
the internet if you're not doing a
podcast you mean it's social media I had
this conversation I talked about this
but one kid from Australia you've been
Australia yeah I made a joke about it on
stage because I was how many did with it
before after you cried on Comedy Central
this before so I didn't lose my
credibility yet this is a report on a
heckler and he told me use the fan of
yours uh holding his clip I will come
down and slap the [ __ ] out of you as big
brown hand a lot of showed up I was a
fan of mine be a heckler what a
douchebag yeah you say weird you know
actually give him a pass he's him okay
he's awesome oh yeah okay kind of that
is um no but the promoter in Australia
he was talking about how he gets grief
from other promoters he's like yeah man
like a lot of these old-school comedians
and a lot of these old-school musicians
they're not getting so they have no
social media presence if they don't do a
podcast they have nothing else so I've
spent all this money with the marketing
toss me my to bring them out here just
when I can spook the guy who has a
[ __ ] clue about Twitter Instagram he
goes you know it's work I did for how
much use zero you did all yourself trust
me nothing to you
why would I use these old kind of bands
these old comedians who have no idea on
social media it was actually in lost in
the shuffle now it's so true I mean and
there's the extreme other end of the
spectrum which is like a YouTube star
that has nothing but draw and no real
show to put on but if it in today's
world if you're actually fits a actual
working artist that cares about their
craft and has a vision and stuff it's a
the perfect time to be in it you're your
own publicist yeah like it's up to you
like others conversations Brian let's
I'm like when you sell tickets man you
know you have a following it's up to you
you can't blast out the day of the show
if people are busy man yeah you can't
see y'all almost got to be it's almost
embarrassing how much yeah hey I'm here
hey I'm here hey I know it's a beat I
know it's annoying hey I'm here yeah I
used to write jokes back in the day when
I wasn't working a lot I used to write
jokes on Twitter like if somebody died
or if something happened I was the first
on the scene now it's literally just all
promotions I mean I don't know what else
to and unlike Twitter it's like hey this
is kill Tony last night this is what we
did
there's kill Tony next week yep I'm
going here this weekend
yep well what else can I say I mean you
know I see it yeah it's just pretty much
it's pretty much it now I mean the jokes
are going to other things I heard I
heard some AI was in the office at CAA
and there was an older comedian there
what's his name
and he was talking his age and he's
saying he's like this is [ __ ] man so
I want to run Twitter and it's grim I
don't self take it he's like dude just
still in 17 bro he's like like we can
have someone do it for you but I choose
not the best way to go you think well
maybe I'll be better I'm like oh my gun
I don't know the guy don't like do not
have someone do it for you man if people
can sniff that a mile away totally
totally it's it's it's a it's a strange
thing man because some of the old-school
comics thought that they were so
untouchable they were invincible forever
because they were the television stars
like we're talking about that changing
format yeah there was one box there was
one screen there wasn't that other
screen and there wasn't that other
screen what the hell have seen is that
damn you it was just that
and it was plugged into one thing and
that was it you want to go way back
there used to be only three channels
right yeah desire you are on Carson
where you weren't and then yeah twenty
six channels comedy central's one of
them and then 75 and then 150 and then
the internet and then Netflix and that
is o and then Hulu and then it's all out
there now so those TV stars are getting
swamped because not only is the thing
bigger it's not just that it's a comedy
is big enough to where people are
realizing you can be a fan of fifteen
guys you see that chick in Australia
that made that cool shirt with all the
podcasts around this yeah it had your
name yeah ends mine yeah people that's
what I'm saying is like people are
realizing now the comedy isn't you know
it's just like anything it's just when
you first find something you did your
gateway in like music when I was growing
up I fell in love with Pink Floyd yeah
right and it was like my gateway to
realizing how powerful music is when I
found other things that were influenced
and this and that but in comedy you can
be a fan of 15 20 30 people it used to
be I love Richard Pryor and you know
like to Harlem right but now because
sense of humors are so different and all
of a sudden your sense of humor can
change based on what you see and based
on the other people that you already
have you know I'm sort of like you know
I have a little bit on stage I you know
I'm pretty like braggadocious and like
Ferrier just very confident yeah well
it's me but I'm leaning into I'm showing
it I'm showing it yeah I can't always
you know I can't you're gonna walk
around so I could have any friends react
like though right right but at the same
time you could because it's so funny
nobody bigger dude's or try not you make
selling it is really just you work out
the crying at the clubs before owing a
no venison see so I was feeling the
trial grow I didn't have a set set you
know I had to throw the tears in this
yeah you're more dramatic this was
always my dream to stay here with the
re-shift oh sorry
that's what I said yeah I realize I have
Oh God doing it
[ __ ] I committed to this lorry
oh my guns them die and I'm dying I
Batman
Oh Micro go insane or actually not ro/di
free rolling at some big country dude
like Walker Texas Ranger Bobby a large
community focusing on my show on Monday
I was he yeah great yeah I don't know
the guy that was his music but him he
seemed like a cool dude on wrong show
he's like dude I've been on Good Morning
America I've done everything is nothing
it's more trash than when I do a podcast
oh yeah so she Rogan oh yeah the same
thing like some of this conversation
with a big company and I recently worked
for I want to get into it yeah and
they're saying well we're thinking about
doing this this I just though shows you
just mentioned my show is by far bigger
reach Rogen's by far a bigger reach you
need to start thinking outside the box
and go on actually podcast tours instead
of doing a press conference that you ear
on Twitter that you're going to get
40,000 views like it doesn't I can
guarantee you this many people will
download the information inside their
ears I can guarantee this is the minimum
can you you can't and and I feel like
the networks never wanted to embrace it
they wanted to always think that the
landscape was there as I worked all my
life to become a television executive
everything is always evolving you know
who the happiest people that came up as
television executives are I know them
they're been Netflix executives or sure
they're the Yankees they're smiling they
get to watch stuff and go you know what
I think we should acquire that I like
that yeah I think that's it those are
those are execs you know those other
execs are given notes to shows thinking
that that's going to change their game
telling your creative people what you
think they're dinosaurs man like I
didn't load I just said this read about
Fox poor chested their big president or
CEO or the [ __ ] use came out talking
about fighting the kids saying we use
their brand to build already on Shannon
Sharpe on Shannon Sharpe cod when I saw
that a slave driver Brian mean
Wow own him on all platforms I'm sure
interruptus is a man like probably got
to talk you cannot do that realize where
we're working together you're a
privileged white male you can't say you
own african-american that is just insane
yeah we own him on all platforms we're
using it it's like his you've just not
up on the times like it like I look at
the the content that they have and that
what they're trying to do online like
they just don't have someone there just
getting passed by right now learning
that [ __ ] you know 68 Camaro I'm
having to test like what are you doing
with the fight you still driving nothing
alright see ya I was having this talk
the other day with with a comedian
friend that has has a show on Comedy
Central and they're like yeah we're
going to make it you know big and fancy
we're gonna you know even bigger and
bigger and fancy Emily you know or you
could make it like what it is it's just
like raw and capture it because people
are really into that they want it to
feel I mean we talked about it with my
Netflix special flick they want it to
feel a little bit dangerous yeah a
little bit under pretty and it was and
it is it is under produced and that's
people get the date that you don't need
the the lights the LEDs behind you that
everybody has those little around LED
every day everybody's everything looks
the same almost you know what I mean and
it's like you don't have to UM the rora
tonight that's a huge part of why
podcasts are doing so great it's because
whoa this isn't all these flashing
lights it's not all these flashing
lights you know for the most part it's
cheap to do so I'll even one up and I'm
going to cut you off it's not even it's
not even the production sometimes it's
the vocalization they just heard me
clear my throat
25 seconds ago I'm like what I'm
thinking why when I did it I'm like wow
I was right into the mic and it seems
like a bad thing
on a honeybee show they go oh can we get
one more time you cleared your throat
there now but to throw clear here almost
looking back on it that's sort of like
well they're just being real you don't
yes I'm gonna start
yeah human yeah well that's the same
thing like when we come in like a what
exactly went to cover and I always just
conversation both like I just want
people to feel like they're sitting on
the couch like this yeah same thing when
I was
doing Bellator this weekend we were
going through big production means this
guy's gonna say this and say this so it
you know I think I think we should ditch
all our notes if you don't know makes
much luck you price shouldn't be sitting
at the desk with us yeah I just wanna
have conversation I don't want to know
what you're gonna say min let's just
make it like a conversation react listen
to what I say you and then you listen
you know and we go back and forth at but
if you're waiting to get out this stat
about filled a.m. if you're wait and get
this stat about phaidor
man did that didn't you're like
everybody else not I know personally I
don't want to do that I don't have fun
doing it yeah and that's how it works
for everything even on it you said it
right there it's listening if people
listen to the other person I think
that's a huge the art the art is
listening listening listening if you're
if you're stinking of the one thing that
happened 10 seconds ago and you try to
get that in after when the windows
closed miss agenda that weird it sounds
overproduced it sounds like you're
forcing in a stat but if they're just
listening and if they're listening hard
enough then they can really find the
moment for their step but it that takes
a while to learn that yeah it's taking
me forever you know I have a problem
interrupting people or you know but now
if I myself listening more under cell
phonee I get you know a wide variety of
comedians to be guests on it you've been
a guest Cal and everybody right bill bar
everybody's going to guest and one thing
I definitely notice is that the writers
that aren't necessarily podcasters and
they stand out different in a very weird
way it doesn't work they don't work on
my show because that they're writing so
hard so China roasts that person or the
comedian or whatever they're thinking so
hard that it passes them by you got me
and Jeremiah running [ __ ] full-court
press yeah behind the back masses of
comedy like we are pushing each other
and you have read ban on sound effects
going off of me and Jeremiah's dance and
then Joel Jimenez the drummer hit your
joke that you wrote 15 seconds ago is so
gone yeah
and now what now you've now you're not
now you're thinking about the jokes
still you've been looking at the MoMA
doing in veggie lost every second two
ticks by and it's just listening man
it's so important and it goes that way
for everything Rogan is the same way
with the UFC you know all those other
guys to his left and right always they
have folders and the son used some
papers and I don't know what what's on
but I know he's not it's not out yet
right now I I asked Rosen the same thing
because we're going to this production
mean that Belpre I'm working with Goldie
but that's a gold partner in crime and I
said I took this mean going since irelia
Mike BA you know whatever your your old
year old boy man yeah who a virtually
identical like joking around cuz me and
him and Roseau love that doing I went
yeah and I was just curious um buddy how
much productions you guys do like not we
listen to each other man yup we're the
perfect combination because we we knew
kind of the vibe of each other we go off
that you I knew you know I do my horse I
knew the fighters I mean the stat I
wouldn't bring that in with me and now
and I'm not knocked on the guys who use
now you listening the guys that aren't
Goulding in art Rogan and it's very
robotic right Harry Fox Purdue's yeah
and this that and that stat and it's not
fun to listen to
yeah which is like when we do though the
Companions we just Kiki do right just
[ __ ] mo over seven of his last nine
fights SEP 7 in a media yeah so some
they're just weird numbers out just
waiting right well it's like also
podcast like there's no producer going
hey Brent God you got I get Tony to
talked about his next special also is
there any way you can talk about your
problems with Fox like like what oh and
make sure you take this stance on George
Carlin and friend we need you to argue
Richard Pryor I don't need that that's
not real man yeah it does that stuff
does not work anymore and the ratings
will support every arguing I'm making
right now the ratings will support that
and advertisers a huge article coming
out might be in Forbes or Newsweek I
forget which one but the time on how
advertisers are just literally jumping
ship on the podcasting because you you
got people so just take our show for
example fine kid or big round break down
three times a week their listeners we
know
this amount of people at the very
minimum or listen I was downloading the
information when given listen the lease
doing this
can you guarantee it with these [ __ ]
ratings on TV no he can't right not at
all and now now with t-bone uh DVRs I
can fast-forward through the commercials
yeah
I'm not watching [ __ ] I switch
channels nobody should be and the people
in you and especially in the comedy
world you know going back to this again
it's like a comedy and I'm not and I'm
sorry to be going off on Comedy Central
but it just seems to be like a perfect
world it's my family now Shiho yeah I
don't want to bring him here at Sophia
but you know if you're watching this a a
one-hour special right let's say you're
at a live comedy show watching somebody
do an hour you've been doing that even
going all around imagine if every 7
minutes some group of people came out on
this stage and for what is this two
minutes or three minutes four minutes
how long's commercials two minutes two
minutes at least so imagine if every
seven minute I'm serious on this stage
you had to stop your black curtain goes
just over you right and then these
people come out and are like life alert
can save your life with this necklace on
if you fall Krenzel what yeah what the
[ __ ] is going on in an active holiday
and then I'm so like I would say yeah
that would be a horrible show but
meanwhile that's how we were on other
than from a great day HBO and Showtime
that was it there was really only and
that's why they were HBO was known as
they that's the play that got a Mecca
Mecca Mecca Mecca Mecca me that was the
mecca that was the mecca yeah I think so
anymore
HBO's not to Mecca Netflix is necklace
because of their algorithm it's all
about putting people in position to see
what they want if you like billboards
and you like Rogen Tony in split yeah I
like to rework recommend these for you
anybody didn't do that you mark that for
your list and the this and that HBO sure
they have the HBO go and I love it now a
huge HBO guy was raised on it somehow
even though my mom didn't have a lot of
money you know we didn't have a lot of
money growing up some house she always
made sure we had HBO I don't know why or
how I guess it was probably part of some
like poor people
package do you like the one thing that
on the HBO dissipates you pay for its
meal with our EBT my Mac I feel like HB
like I see I feel like you're doing
something right if you're on Showtime
you still doing something right I would
like all the cool kids are Netflix
aren't they totally and I'm not again
I'm not deadly showing them where HBO
set they've got hard on cubby central
those are my employees so but it's we're
talking about a landscape yeah and it's
great for the consumer so if you think
we're just talking about this like all
they're talking about coming out what
it's like to be a comedian now we're
talking about for everybody like this is
a historical moment but tell me central
you'll adapt the thing is is like dusty
says retain show they have to adapt and
more they just disappear like dinosaurs
you don't say ah oh my goodness yeah I
do they have to adapt they would they
would have to otherwise well he's gonna
give in like nah we're sticking on the
tube we're just [ __ ] no man 9:00 p.m. we
got [ __ ] commercials up the ass we
know there's the Netflix on that we're
just going to keep writing this out
let's give them six hours of hours of
tosh point-o i think we're watching it
did i think you're already want to
imagine if I would have said 15 years
ago that there's those blockbusters
which are on every corner are going to
be literally a punch on a slap your warm
literally a violent line blockbuster I'm
lost blockbusters Friday night that
place was so come you didn't line like a
and then there's line for the candy I
get some of those snow caps and get some
Twizzlers are sad yeah [ __ ] is a good
time but then we get the front made like
you owe $200 as a charge and my mom
every time we go come on let's just
let's pay attention let's just get
through this one great make some kid
like alright and then we trudged back
yes mom and sometimes guide like nope
baby out of the copy of the thing that
you wanted oh I mean how does a new
movie you want to see there was none
another
a whole wall and they just have the
covers and there's no deviation behind
of heartbreaking I'll show the friend
like he did he won't turn in the new die
heart - it's Friday night you silly Bob
no no one can do think about it now what
if you hit the thing on your Netflix I
was like sorry too many people are
watching that's right that's a
heartbreak kids will never know that
[ __ ] this Hancock would crash the kids
will never know that pain ever ever
when dressed part came on VHS I went to
get in just God like damn - I cried my
dad like the [ __ ] up Mel you feel like
crying save it for when your old man on
Comedy Central I totally forgot about
that you I'm not about not having the
thing there yeah
you bought yeah blockbusters a big deal
then they did they're like I just get
with the times let's do red box the
dollar and but you still got to bring it
back be like not too much work
yeah I mean red boxes [ __ ] gun yeah
the Netflix and on-demand like now we'll
do this and now what they're doing is
paramount Universal Sony all they were
trying to figure out how to bring new
release movies straight to your home so
the theater which they make all the
money
yeah like Netflix like oh you guys like
Will Smith yeah he's a big movie star
his next movies come out just on Netflix
yeah we're doing a deal just on Netflix
my boy Todd filming this guy producer he
did you know training day he did [ __ ] in
all these movies he just shot this movie
with Will Smith and out goes straight to
your access I mean they changed the game
look here's what I think if you want to
hear something interesting that hit me
recently is please I think we're
probably three to five years until they
start talking about the Oscars being on
Netflix
let's find Emmys being on we're so
imagine if Netflix made a deal I'll give
you two imaginary worlds a Netflix makes
a deal with a sport 100 percent if they
got their hands on just spitballin here
the UFC or you name it I mean the NFL FL
is that in but gained with the minute
creamin live right yeah sure
and it is very close there yeah this is
all right I mean right around the corner
just like with all the other evolutions
of everything Twitter is starting to do
right there yeah yeah they're right
there and it's I mean that's what
they're doing by the way if you really
think about it's like wait that's
streaming X with live where we're
watching it you streaming on NBC live is
live so for watching it on if they make
a deal and they're loading up on money
you know they're really cute yeah I miss
ya they can't mess up north goes to just
finish there's one you want another
imaginary one what if Netflix bought
South Park what happens then if South
Park I don't know what their contract is
of Comedy Central but I'm you know we
know it's huge right let's just the flat
a it's awesome sense right exactly let's
say it's 100 million for whatever five
years or whatever I don't know way more
than right but they can they can
literally know Netflix is like a the
king on Game of Thrones like they can
behead people to do whatever they want
torture them there but then they just
want content yeah
because if but also if you're South Park
and for other reasons coming soon
there's not making moves but you know
that they're supposed to be doing this
day relevant Netflix like don't you want
your all this art you put together and
you want to live on here's the biggest
platform we're in every city in the
world in and you think for South Park
doesn't want to all of a sudden be seen
in Australia in a Japan in agree
everywhere they're everywhere
I don't think I didn't even really
realize until I went to Australia in
November that I've been ever last to
November's but I didn't really realize
the comedy central's not a thing they're
like those shows aren't even a thing
they're sometimes they take one thing
and they'll have one thing on their
comedy network even Canada it's a comedy
Network and they nitpick they'll take
you know it's like Jimmy Kimmel at 9:00
p.m. from ABC we and I'll have you know
maybe South Park rerun at 10:30 we are
going to do they get to sort of nitpick
Australia is just pretty much they just
don't it
not didn't happen in there so there's a
statues of you over there in Australia I
love them some Tony huge group other
coming I'm just get made comedy comics
down there it's unbelievable and and
that is Netflix that nothing get regular
the difference is which is why our
friend was like men I need be on Netflix
so if we it you know again going back to
it if we had a podcast on a Comedy
Central show that's great because the
people in Australia will hear the
podcast but they can't see the Comedy
Central show but at the same person as a
Netflix special and they listen to your
podcast they check out your Netflix
special there then they then they have
you your world while you're in then I
would from every podcast forever they're
waiting for the next special it's the
it's the difference in the world
and one little sliver called America
which in our box is a big deal but it's
a whole round crazy planet it's only why
I think it's only North Korea that
doesn't have it
I sure who is a limit them even if they
do I think even North Korea there's a
few people like stealing passwords their
Netflix sure there's a couple Tony
Hinchcliffe family yeah better watch
your [ __ ] mouth tone to him alright
yeah even was I add this idea and I
brought to Fox and Brad Fox by two years
ago when I was with them but the English
pot like podcasting is not really
available all over like if you're in
China if you're in Brazil if you're you
know that it's all in English which it
limits you how far you can go so I had
the idea to get two translators that
were pretty animated and could read
would do listen to our podcast and redo
it are you serious in Chinese and
Portuguese Wow that's insanity
oh no we won't do first sake but Fox
know man well no well that's not my idea
by the way I would watch every episode
of the fighter and the kid in Chinese
right ooh I cry on the comedy situa Oh
oh I finally have my chance to river my
dream air and I cry like a baby
anything where is the aureus oh well
they wouldn't be seen in terribly if I
don't know I need all right old useless
oh I cry so hard on the comedy stage
work do you come out of my eyes
oh why am I so big and muscular am i
crying uh-oh am I finally get my chance
to tell a story
oh and I thought of a sudden it tears
come out of my are arrived but always
why did I tell you I excuse me sir it's
not 2007 I'm not a big deal
it's super addictive there it is baby
crap I can't move I told you so I give
it I leave it off with ugh oh oh yeah
there's some in about like I mean it's
just like there's certain things that
just cut me right to the core and like a
big tough guy like I was holding a tea I
was like my every photo be like damn
that's really cool man I'm such a
special moment and I thought as you know
two or three days I'm gonna get roasted
by the roastmaster I was like cool ban
just kind of not acknowledge and move on
nope robust up oh my god oh my god I
love ideas all right Chinese have
absolute transit I hope they just edit
everything else out of your story out
and it's just you crying up there so
much and they're like we need to mix it
that's the end credits
I mean was she crying just credit oh my
god did you uh moving on yeah I cried
big deal man
so we can of songs that wanted to make
you cry
cyborg ID on your girl cyborg add on the
big round breakdown and I listen you
good story right I did and it'll be
somewhat of a fan
now um you know what the only thing that
I don't like and I ended up getting you
know I listened to that episode and the
one thing that it's like look here's my
theory and that's it bullying it's not
bullying if you're a celebrity it's not
bullying and I think a lot of these
fighters and I've been seeing it lately
someone the other day was like someone
sent me sexual advances right someone
says one of the lighter look a dick pic
yeah they're getting rid on female via
one of the girls and it's like she's
active I can't remember I said yourself
it's like their fight these fighters are
realizing that they're celebrities I
think for the first time and yeah don't
look at your Twitter don't look at your
Instagram I deal with it I'm a comedian
and it's everybody has it if you're if
people know who you are you're going to
end up I get your public figures I'm
just yeah exactly and you know that's
fair to say but but so I'm trying to
think how it could really do so let's
say your specials Kate you're a
different animal you're [ __ ] roast
master and you but so let's say your
slush came out your new special and you
get 1000 comments like ah the worst [ __ ]
I've ever seen her it's get it it's
gonna affect you a little bit yeah
that's you don't think that's a form of
bullying no it's not bullying people are
just people are too sensitive
yeah we're living at a time where that's
part of the catch if I want to read the
10,000 comments let's say new fan
where'd you come from unbelievable blah
blah blah those outweigh this out I'm
not staring at the thousand I'm Poe and
then we know for a fact exactly we know
for a fact that cyborg has a huge
awesome loyal following I know I know
that first half because they've you know
they do them they're not my biggest fan
because of you know the jokes or
whatever in her calling me out saying
that she didn't like my jokes yeah
and just fair yeah it's not a Brazilian
thing getting roasted is not a Brazilian
thing yeah I think it's I think it's
tough in general because she does it you
know she doesn't know you I think that's
what me I think you would a Jew
giving you a pass it was you in Jeremiah
yeah kill Tony show yeah but when it's
the president of UFC Dana White and and
Joe Rogan the face of the USC on a plane
that I think that's where it's personal
for her because then you have two people
who were let's be honest supposed to
have her back to some degree and they're
all laughing at it
was it funny for sure that's what you do
you're [ __ ] comedian yeah Joe gets a
little bit of pass because these
comedian right first and foremost your
comedian you have to when best communes
in the world also one of the best
Roasters but then you got the president
of company you know I'm saying like
imagine if you weren't a comedian you
were working somewhere and you walk in
and the president he's like just
roasting the [ __ ] out of you
yeah like god damn in yeah um that's
like a normal job though that happens in
real life it still be the loss of the
boss isn't that bullying to a certain
extent if he didn't make a joke Dana
didn't make a joke and he I think he
laughed based on the moment the timing I
think that I don't even think he was
really laughing at the joke at all the
context about look it's like this it's
like Trump said grab them by the [ __ ]
and that's what people remember that's
what you know people are like oh he said
he's a horrible he have any Sonny knows
that I love [ __ ] yeah but if you really
start it 45 seconds before that and
listen to what he's saying to some guy
who they're out during a commercial
brain being done with whatever it is
yeah but there it is yeah exactly
they're in between commercials and
they're talking about what it's like
being recognized what it's like being
you know a mess right exactly and it's
and it's it is taken out of context
because he is talking about the types of
girls that come up to him and are
hanging out with you and it's easy yeah
that bully Bush take a back seat yeah
because it's not exactly one sliding in
IBM and I think that's clearly with
Trump's doing there's he's like you know
Billy I mean when you're like me and
he's a confident dude obviously a huge
ego and he's just like dude it's [ __ ]
easy and it [ __ ] grab these girls and
that last part is grab them by the [ __ ]
and the last part of our thing was in a
cutter dick off to make weight or
whatever have
and I was your problems interview with
psy problem interview
well it wasn't that what happened was I
listened to the interview and I heard or
complain about being bullied by
everything and I guess there you know
yeah there is there is almost something
to the context of that situation with
Rogen and Dana but it also goes back to
us talking about how it's these are
dangerous what we talked about anything
can happen in these unproduced podcasts
that we were on a plane ride sitting in
the first pod of the front of a Qantas
flight coming back from Australia fresh
off of Holly Holm growing a piece of
lumber at Ronda Rousey's neck I mean we
are we're all coming off of this crazy
ride and you know he's just he was sort
of an innocent bystandard and that with
rhodium egging me on saying we should do
a UFC Rose how how who would you who it
all happened so quick who would well who
would we roast Joe I don't know cyborg
and I go well where would we start and
you know when I mean it like it so happy
where you so quickly that we also can't
as comedians in this is one part yes we
can't you know the listeners that have a
problem with that are the same people
that laughed at a joke from a comedian
this week that came up with a joke
because he wasn't censoring yourself
because he wasn't going out it's the
nicest way and you can't be worried
about her and feeling right sometimes
it's a risk that we live or die with and
you know you move forward I can
understand from both angles and anyone
knows we I do not play both sides I
never play both sides so I listened to
the cyborg thing and I was sort of
perked about it but I didn't want to you
know start anything or do anything but
then two days later she punches that
girl she punched her in the face because
a girl that's smaller
I'd rather and a gold I not rolled out a
girl that a girl she's not that small
but a girl that was literally making fun
of her bullying because the new form of
bullying in this Vimal sense to do it
because it happened with my cousin the
new form of bullying is cyber bullying
because when we are kid
I get bullied at school my [ __ ] when we
are doing I got to deal with it the next
morning at school I don't go [ __ ] when I
do get home I go online like oh my god
it's here
and when gangs up on him and social
media these days so big that's the worst
form of bullying because now everyone
sees it's just not the few students now
everyone sees it so in that case and I
defense I board in this case because my
girl was country making fun or online
trolling her and remember she's another
professional fighter right and she
didn't think she was going to run into
her and I like it because there is a
there's gonna be some repercussions for
your actions you really think that
support it 100's because I'd say right
now it's my kid is getting bullied at
school yeah he's like dad this kid will
not stop messing me I go listen you
spend for like a day or two I don't know
in this new day day and age you might go
to prison for 12 years what you're gonna
do is when he does that tomorrow you
socked him right in the face I hear he
stops I agree
guarantee stops I agree with that now
this girl he's had out we found out what
kind of character she is she keeps going
she got kicked out of her gym her own
teammates like she's a bad person look
you know I'd say it's like it's not
professional fighters to me it's not
like if you roasted me for cryin time
central a punch in the face then I'm the
bully if you're another professional
fighter and you're roasting me on
Twitter
non-stop vicious [ __ ] and then we come
face-to-face and like I'm a fresh
fighter you profess about it what do you
wanna do now you don't say but what
didn't it sort of look like a sucker
punch toot and it's sort of feel I got
in know where the real fighter though
like you're talking talking like I
you're not saying I guess but I mean I
get was like aging as a oh my god that's
[ __ ] up she's climbing little pretty
thing but it's like that girl's not
small and I'm not as a man on honey
other girls side I'm just saying I find
it strange that someone goes from being
complaining about getting bullied to
punching someone in the face that hasn't
been flagged for steroids in the past
yeah but see the steroid things like
telling do we hang on to that for how
long she tested she's been tested more
than anyone everybody I think that's a
good question for a doctor I'd love to
ask like if you take the steroids
because this is so interesting to me and
no one really knows but what they do
know with the statue
I think I heard Luke Thomas talked about
this because almost laws they say if you
do steroids it gives you about a ten
percent advantage speed quickness
strength about ten percent you really
think that's it just ten first I was
surprised of her it was surprised at 10
percent I think it's 30 40 I don't know
I don't know at that level I do not know
because they learn so 1% is enormous at
a world class level if you can get one
up one percent advantage on your [ __ ]
brain opponent oh my god in track and
field you're talking about huge distance
in mixed martial arts a 1 percent
advantage [ __ ] up I will do some [ __ ]
for whatever stress and when they say
damn they say I don't know that's the
difference in all those punch landing or
McGregor's punch landing is 1% ya know
all that's why I don't know if I'd give
it 10 percent I 10 percent to me at that
level so hot it's well I mean you also
have to rely mean yeah I'm just saying
we have to factor in a recovery I mean
is the tempest the biggest thing that's
the biggest thing do you see a recovery
but the other thing is is with cyborg
so she failed once do we just chalk it
up that all her accolades all her hard
work is from steroids that's not fair
maybe maybe I'll come on maybe and do
that maybe it's not fan watched you
watch Vitor Belfort think you watch it
oh you know you don't think it wants
Josh Barnett I do dude but don't you
agree that it's different to men taking
steroids or a man taking steroids
against another man because it's male
testosterone so it's men against men I
wanted more testosterone than that one
but women a woman against a woman if one
of the women has male testosterone
that's totally stand out different it
can be a bigger effect for sure my god
let me ask you just owned a huge you
think yeah out of cyborgs entire career
none other female has ever done steroids
as she fought oh that she fought in
Brazil heck yeah I'm Charlene the you'll
see and Invicta you don't you think if
you think she's in the only division in
the world where everyone's clean I mean
there's no we're taking this long thing
I really really I kept trying to scan my
mind look here
Lancer let me tell you why I hate to
tell you all those other girls are
taking [ __ ] as well in the USC promise
you Yoani NJ check get out of here I'm
watching her on Instagram I'm watching
her eat the proper out meal now I'm
watching her put the instead of sugar on
her things she's eating the agave or
whatever you know [ __ ] monster my
thing I'm Wilding her hit the heavy bag
and run out it up a mountain and Rosie's
factory might see sideboards [ __ ]
training it's nuts when she does 50
miles a day and like what are you doing
did you do this what I'm saying though
we can just we can reason we know she's
250 miles a day that's what I'm saying
is the difference if III know of a horse
that runs 50 miles a day
it's got a lot of testosterone running
third it's a horse
goddamn it Tony I'm saying you can't
just chalk up everything she did the
steroids that's not fair I know then you
got to do that for most of it vastly
that you enjoy I promise you most of
them have dabbled in illegal supplements
or have been convicted of illegal
supplements convicted I'd look the guy
okay and I get it and a bear fighter
Yoani Anton Nate Diaz Yohan enj check-in
Nate Diaz and they Diaz eats fish he
doesn't even he's avid pescetarian he's
a thirsty turn any you think what do you
think uh you know he's never been busted
obviously but if we go as far as legal
summons he smokes weed on stop yeah now
that some people think that's an
advantage so do you want chopped up
hitting crazy I agree I don't think very
many times the other way no high ROI he
laid down on the ground fight Manchin
Silva oh and I stood up I popped up I'll
never forget that moment by the way I
saw Goldie and Rogan stand up out of
their seats no I mean literally they
were just hyped it was low wasn't that
wasn't the stand-up one that was Holly
Holm Ronda Rousey we all just their
chairs went back I mean I was very
unbelievable earth-shattering but I
remember seeing Joe slamming I heard
this thing when when when he laid down
against Anderson Silva because I was
literal at Hulk you know I'm an old pro
wrestling fan yeah I know that
yeah I thought how this is this is a
gimmick a look
hears and he goes both ways I liked it
as a setup because you don't know what's
coming afterwards right if he wins I
we're in for a bad fight when he did
that without a sight to give us up yeah
I mean I how was the fight it was not a
great right exactly but at the same time
you know I mean you take balls to do
that and that's why I like the Diaz is
like the they have huge balls which I
enjoy but what I'm saying to you is but
Nate did crawl in the Connor said doing
his stuff and that round two I mean you
know you watch it again he's literally
well you know you for sure he still lost
the fight no Nate beat Conor and in the
first crush well I'm saying lost asset
you did same thing the second one was a
valiant one I mean it was Connors you
know jogging away and stuff still when
the fight though according to the judges
score that's all we care about in this
last I guess you know I'm saying and
then you have that one will jump you
watched it honey I've seen it went on
times she's it now is now Connor been in
trouble if there's a six round yeah it
was a street fight that would be in
trouble but that's not our sport right I
won't even entertain those RJ you're
like whoop there's a six round oh and
what happens if [ __ ] short Jets
limiting some time argument sometimes
going back to the Nick Diaz
Anderson Silva thing I feel like there
is something to sometimes using that
psychology I don't think it worked in
fanner since Silva you know I think he
takes that back puts his hand great on
right all I'm saying is so your favorite
fighter and obviously Nate Nick and
never done steroids very clear but it
you people they make exceptions for
people that it works for them their
favorite fighters favorite athletes and
then they want to destroy the ones that
they don't like because maybe they had
this hiccup in the past again
I mean look steroids the steroids I just
raised a pro wrestling fan like I again
I don't have that big of a problem with
the guys that are on I understand that
part I get it but to me there's truly
something that I find strange about a
woman and hey why aren't the other ones
getting popped if all the ladies are
doing it I mean I'm not really not at
all tomorrow
I'm saying the odds of that
throughout their our along their career
20 years whatever is Duran to me at that
high level fighting Holly who all these
girls at one point or another I would be
baffled if none of them ever of cyborgs
opponents have ever dabbled in similar
drugs I would be dumbfounded if none of
them in the history of cyborgs fighting
career none of them have dabbled in the
legal supplements if you tell me I've
like holy fire you [ __ ] me good for them
that's nuts
yeah because in the men's division
you're [ __ ] I could go through you
and tell you the guys spent a lot better
on it yeah I didn't get busted yeah it's
an interesting thing sport professional
sports totally all the way around all
the way around and I think that they're
going to find out later on that it would
just be better that if everybody was
completely clean like it should just be
very buddy
well now with you sada do you know
they're so strict so you're getting
everyone clean ratings are down we have
no stars guys are getting injured is
that what it was though I don't think
Rhonda was a star because of that I
don't think Connor is a star because of
steroids
maybe I mean I don't know no and I would
say they are I'm just saying you're
getting less finishes you're getting
more decisions you're getting guys not
be able to fight as frequently you made
it so strict don't can do anything right
and the reason you did that isn't
because of the safety of the fighters
the reason you did that so you could
sell to this huge come and go look we're
legit we have testing you don't have to
worry about the Jon Jones getting busted
anymore because now we're doing this
yeah that's why they did it I'm excited
for that one Cormier Jon Jones yes
are you going to that I'm not gonna make
it you look laughing you want to and the
last one was uh New York City where were
we where was that did you get Rogan see
Julia the best season it's whack a
doodle
laughs did I not see any animals hey I'm
so close to it that I sometimes I'm
sitting there and it feels like I'm on a
you know season three if this is not
happening
essential and I could just tear out
addresses only if you want to slide it
dude your girl y'all you only got a
stylist man she's looking better and
better I'm a fan
I was living there the whole time how
dare you would you hit that light below
you look like brother and sister just
had the white polo Don stop the white
[ __ ] business sure she's killing it
man and you know that's a big part of my
whole thing is that I love always have
loved the women's divisions I think that
you know they're so awesome and and
there's so it's a different type of like
style or personal like so it's kind of
people you're such a misogynistic Pig
it's more caddy like it's so personal
because they feel like they still have
to prove that they belong so you getting
these heart warming like heart [ __ ]
heart yeah it's all heart
yeah it's scrappy yeah now I like one
time it was the top five mm-hmm
it's outside that it gets a little
tricky I can go to the an amateur show
out here no see and see better
competition out of all the sports
I feel like UFC is the one or MMA is the
one in which it's not a joke it's like
almost cooler in a way and I'm with you
on that top five thing but I'm just
saying like over like compared to the
WNBA like if they have a different color
basketball they have a different what
yeah thing is silly
well the the the women's team I think
felt like the New York Liberty and they
were playing a game when we were doing
our production means when I was at
Bellator from that Square Garden and the
guys are around there's females down
went fellas there we get ready to play a
game if we went full Juwanna Mann got
wigs got our jerseys could we beat them
I said who played high school basketball
here like one guy raised him like I
don't think we'd beat a man I think we
get [ __ ] hoop done yeah probably by
the pretty [ __ ] good the New York
Liberty not sure but I agree like with
other women's sports like they just
hated on Serena Williams right did John
McEnroe was like she wouldn't she would
be like 40th place or four hundredth
place or some [ __ ] like that
I think tennis is close to their like
women's and men's I actually prefer
watching Serina over any of the dudes
Serena's sort of an interesting than
that though yeah actually tennis balls I
mean I've been in her locker mouths and
I watch your racquet ball me dog
her head low he gave my hand ball with
her I bet yeah I bet you for that she
dragon and she's pregnant but yeah as
far as women yeah women sliding this is
bout is equal not only if it's hot top
left like top level you don't say it's
not top level it's [ __ ] it's not good
let's go to current events what you got
chin woo what's up dawg
will mix up ants how's your podcast go
how's the first guest ever it's going
great yeah you where you in fact you
named my show the Tony our opponents
gone so great we just had big Jay
oakerson on last week it was i dead for
show where i just sort of sit down and
have like a it's not even as fun as this
it's literally like a real conversation
i try to get inspired and find really
impelling stuff out yeah no we shouldn't
straight me on pony out are you doing
pony our shirts on your tour um I'm
waiting to figure out exactly what I'm
doing with you going on tour uh in
August I should take them with me
have a sponsor to this yeah definitely
let me pull and say such a much do you
pay cash yeah I hate money now and a
pony our shirt be sick yeah yeah ideas
for days
yeah black shirt gold logo like an
old-school like be sick me a shiny coho
knee our yeah sick yeah i man yeah we'll
figure it up I would he got chin first
one is cyborg there you go well she's
out of her fight with Megan Anderson but
she's going to fight Tonya Avenger
instead to Invicta Chand
are you guys familiar with Tonya and
that she's a real real pro yeah for this
one I don't know Tonya is just a random
girl on Twitter that started trolling
cyborg and now they made this fight
happen
it's basically bully beatdown town um
yeah so yeah the bummer about Megan
Anderson is Megan is and she was a girl
who is an actual threat to cyborg she
was similar-sized good skills
Invicta champ ranked number one at 145
coming over the UFC so this is a fight
everyone to see if you don't know who
Megan incident is you were gonna you're
definitely going to she's also a good
looking girl like she's attractive you
can mark around her she's Australian
she's fun to watch man
Pat it out like go to Instagram she's a
sexy girl and hate today but that goes
into building a star just does that's
kind of yeah either certain parts and
now she's pulled out because of personal
issues which I'm sure I'll have her
released that stuff but you know it's
nothing people go I think she was scared
nothing to stop all that [ __ ] she
was not scared it happened to do it with
some some other stuff and also not your
thing has nothing with tests or anything
like that so in comes [ __ ] homegirl
that she's gonna fight now I'm Evan jure
she looks like she needs fresh Oh some
conkers over though oh wait a second
what is that Tonya Evan she's about to
get oh yeah with yeah this isn't gonna
go good oh geez what is did why does she
look like every bad slow bartender at a
dive so it's like a real shitty version
of Sarah Connor terminated one that's
what she looks like
goodness she just looks like ya ain't
god bless her man for taking the fight I
mean I don't think there's a lot of
girls that would sign up for this this
is not gonna last long look at frickin
the dimepiece gina carano next door
she's sort of haughtiness oh sort of
numero uno pounds round number one
female real lighter look slice who I
hope you Ohana is not hearing me
I'm the biggest crush on her you do love
her my real it's so interesting to me is
because she so it's such a beast like
skill-wise everything I feel like we
find her physically attractive yeah I
don't think she's badly oh he got it
you got a fear like Halle Berry in her
next each other you going with her Halle
Berry yeah I'm going with the 30 yeah
I'm going with the 32 year old champion
I'm not going with Halle Berry
what is this some what I mean look how
he buried what is this 2007 yeah coming
out world
Halle I never thought it was gonna
happen I can't believe I got to be with
you
looky we wanna do it I got bullied as a
kid when I was in school dad
don't not excitable neck huh hey this is
some girls record yeah Tanya having just
a record but she's a bad way champ right
look at that record though ain't bad now
I wish she lied at all she lost to Sara
McMann Alexis Davis nothing wrong with
that Alexis Davis Gina Carano
submission choke Gina Carano interesting
uh you know so she's doing work I mean
you can market this fight you look at
her what she's been doing Invicta she's
been doing work man
just a different animal she's a
completely different animal when you're
fighting cyborg yeah all of her fights
are in Kansas City for some reasons
we're Invicta I think is based on oh oh
okay that makes sense see I get it now
beautiful Kansas City me beautiful yeah
I will not be going tore out that ah
yeah I'd she screwed yeah I mean a
million answered it I was kind of
excited for I think she's a real monster
and a real threat and actually you know
and I this way I would say to her is um
I think it's for the best I think I come
to the UFC you get whatever issues you
need figure out you build your name or
instead of jumping right into the deep
end fighting side board that is not a
fun experience right get the contract
get the fans more familiar with you and
then do more of a mega fight and get
paid more trained these are the times
and use the time to train yeah for sure
yeah cyborg is throwing on I think it's
the only way you can look at it what
else you got you another fight fell
through so Dallas Ronnie is injured and
he's not heavy fighting Robbie Lawler
for 213 but they're going to most likely
move to 214 those two guys are going to
literally beat the poop out of each
other there's going to be poop and
they're going to beat you guys are going
to hit each other continuously am I
crazy to think that this might be one of
the crazier fights ever surrounding
dollar
yeah phenomenal site this is actually I
think the third time they've tried to
book this fight and hopefully I have no
idea what's going on with Cicero knees
injury but I
picture it can't be great if they're
just you know it can't be too bad if
they're just pushing it back a few weeks
I picture this fight literally coming
down like I picture round them round
five literally loud right crowd all the
way up they just have enough energy to
throw one punch at a time like a pro
wrestling on the other one respond like
the movies take it yeah I really just I
mean you just you guys really I think
someone's getting finished well if you
had if you had oh I see this is such an
X Factor fight because it's such an up
in there if I don't know the odds are
because cowboy come off that loss to
Maslow doll he needed a rest it really
[ __ ] him in like they took advantage
of being the cowboy no take anything
anytime there's mobs with all this
monster you didn't he just get [ __ ]
punch in the face of concussed by Matt
Brown yeah he's cowboy the ho be fine
now and he [ __ ] up your title shot now
you're not getting a title shot so he
takes time off so now he's rested which
is great for cowboy but also caliber to
be active to deal with the nerves so now
he's fighting Robbie Lawler Robbie
Lawler new camp day off from the fight
before he's like I'm not ready and he
finds camp what kind of version of
Robbie Lawler getting after you got
knocked out by Woodley so it's like
who's going to come to the cage I don't
think it's going three rounds okay some
skin clip yeah I honestly I what do we
know what the Cerrone injury is what's
undisclosed I don't know but I wonder
what it is for them to move back yeah
sure I can find out and I should I'll
take I'll take Cerrone now or I'll take
I'll take does Ron it's not it's not
helping some main event so it's going to
be how did he lose them up at all I
can't remember got tko'ed Oh bad Oh bad
bed yeah you know really more thing I
walk to the restroom during that fight
where was that I wasn't as a heifer
wasn't oh okay that'd be sooner
done a Broomfield I think in front of
his whole family I think that so he said
right through his grandma never this
terrible - way to go
oof all right the next one is the
bachelor in paradise the scandal were
that girl Corrine accused the other guy
I think Demario Jackson I want to say
accused him of sexual assault
they did an investigation turns out it's
all good it wasn't sexual assault but
now they're going to do a read
for that that series and they're only
allowing a two-drink maximum per hour
because of that issue the to drink
wouldn't want to be give me two straight
vodkas I'm guessing that you have white
girl wasted in every hour yeah they're
going to realize real quick that some
yeah everybody's boring yeah actually to
drink max that's why I'm the Ultimate
Fighter like if I was like damn I'm
starving because you could get order
what do you want I'm like can I just get
some beef like grill some ham because
like we'll get it when we can hours and
hours later like a user I can get vodka
god damn yes what made the show exciting
especially this show with these people
these people aren't even personality no
I'm Stacy and I'm in here paradise
because I feel like I could find someone
it really can exit all these truly loves
doesn't true love all food and then this
hope the poor Demario Jackson with that
Kareem elympios one of the [ __ ] name
is she here she is the biggest [ __ ]
tease in the world gets drunk takes her
clothes off jumps in the pool with him
he's drunk they're making out now this
is because he has a girlfriend now she
wants to press boyfriends sexual assault
charges I don't know anything about that
but that's all blaming and I don't want
to know anything about it why know so
much about it's disappointing how do you
know so much of a Miami I know what
happened I know once they saw you crying
on Comedy Central they thank you I call
you I come on this show they send you
I'm ready [ __ ]
really ray because then you a basket for
people that cry I don't look I'm not a
bachelor in there what else yet it was
very organic sake right and what else
this one is trippy a German white woman
she did a chemical tan to make her skin
really dark and now she could she wants
to be a black woman she considers
herself a black woman I can look at her
I think I've seen isness the Wayans
brothers what's the name of this movie
again white chicks this is a look yeah
she looks identical to the light chick
yeah I've seen but like laughter
opposite away around though
Oh little white to relax I turned into a
black girl
I feel like that's easier had German
that's her whoa drop in the end bump can
we talk about for a second the fact that
she has her titties gigantic gigantic
gigantic blue milk chocolate titties oh
my good until we talk about them big old
chocolate titty lack of a very nice
sweeter the Hawaiians okay yes we have
been Jesus we deserve a juice hold on
guys this that's not white German lady
look at her on Instagram I have good
news the breast filled up on Monday went
well and I have 250 CCS more each breast
furthermore I've done the next step in
my transformation I like the beautiful
big lips of the black woman very much
smiley face wow this is like this is
like of a black woman it felt her god
damn lose some black titties oh my god
I'm into this chick I'm not mad at Sundy
and I like it I want to see what's going
on just like a little chocolate-covered
Easter Egg or something like that with
vanilla underneath yeah swag of a black
girl but nice like a white girl once you
go black you eventually could go back it
appears with this thing that chemical
tans going to wash off in a weird way
that's gonna be wrong with shower weeks
from now when he's not going weird and
melting off yes like i like the lips of
a black woman very much very much
hi she's mentally stable yeah sure I bet
she's just a peach to hang out with yeah
I mean there's no [ __ ] mental illness
German come black white German woman
wants to be black Barbie doll
interesting she's like she's the only
chick on both the guest list and
Schindler's List good a black Barbie
[ __ ] widow Fiat is alright this is in
New York those little sky rides at Six
Flags
mmm a girl fell off of it but it's just
kind of weird let's see here so she ends
up falling a Cotter I was like 25 feet
Jesus Christ but they did an
investigation and the rides perfectly
fine the station
everything's fine so they're not even
sure what happened exactly is but I mean
she's 14 years old she was with her
brother I'm guessing she was sort of
fight or something or she's got
horseshoes I act on the way I do I know
this is an exclusive but I actually know
what happened to her there she was on
the ride and she was watching her phone
and she has the Comedy Central app yeah
she's watching the new this is not
happening she sees he's right when Shopp
facing before his bullets or season four
so she saw Brendan Schaub crying and
she's like I can't deal with this
anymore I'm jumping out of here it
brothers like I don't know if that's
gonna kill youse I mean we're like I
don't know 20 feet above the grab she's
like I don't care I need to get out of
this thing I have to get ready phone off
nice one in my life I can never go back
I'll tell you man you know Six Flags is
shady that seems like one of the most
fun rides I've ever seen there that
seems like a safe fun little uh no what
is that ride by the way that's a lame
thing that just goes around the park you
have my parents who want to [ __ ] go
on what's the last theme park you might
do um it was Universal City I actually
enjoy it
me too transformers the rides you do
that I haven't been Universal muse yeah
to Disney located a few years ago and
the Transformers right it's like you're
being thrown around by the guys in New
York City they are like they lift you it
feels like they're just throwing you
around a city and all this stuff shut
don't want the [ __ ] line to blend two
new people in yeah yeah I do a thing
where I am I have a special wheelchair
where I hide my legs in the in lot I all
now I'm good would be perfect
ball at night now raise your chin I get
pissed so hard but that's Russia yeah
it's pissed first
all right the next one is an old Chinese
lady for good luck she threw coins into
the engine of a plane oh and look a
little hood rook to us we are going to
have a very rookie fry
I always threw the changing two into the
brain in GA the best of rope to earth
I'm so smart
welcome back to the fighter in the key
translated version I think that what
happened so ah silly old [ __ ] so I'm
going through the chat engine sometimes
for good rock until bricks into it we're
gonna have the best luckiest fright ever
if we get a lock any which one is crazy
big eyes you have a safe flight run gg
gg and you know what happened I was like
good morning america I said delay the
flight like six hours a slap a [ __ ]
along with you that looks like a goddamn
puddle of water in the middle of a mall
why the [ __ ] does that look like a lucky
fountain what's wrong with you lady
oh it is long as standing traditions we
always thought a a pocket blue changing
today seven billion dollar plane engine
so smart of us and so what do we do you
are we do you know what we do yeah I do
a nickel a dime a quarter a vvd
centerpieces yeah I think the visi cent
piece is the one they blew up the engine
is she the worst lady ever John she's
flying out of China away
I wish us all the best of luck thank you
thank you
Crowder boy vixen sometimes I shoot a
gun at the pilots head for good luck
well he frying the pain oh good luck on
our landing we're going to need it just
the first two words [ __ ] customer
ever fly woods
some behind yours sometimes I change
into the front of the engine it comes
back as in the back in paper form
the engine is like a Coinstar machine
you throw the change in the front a
little piece of paper come out in the
back tell you how much you can turn
anything just to receipt for oh yeah
oh I am like I just lost my entire Asian
fan base today which was chin or your
fenders I'm pretty sure worn out sure
yes that is my Asian fan he's not
offended is that is all for convinced
Champa knee you want more I want I want
more give me one more good now yeah I'm
into this yeah this one Hale is um this
is a very sweet story
this lady opened a coffee shop and
employed 40 adults with mental
disabilities and the main reason she did
it is because two of her kids have
disabilities and then she thought that
if though those kids could be able to
work and be functional in this
particular job yeah man i watch that
show born this way on the river scene
there yeah but I can't stop watching it
are you kidding me are you but I mean oh
I'm serious you [ __ ] with me know
who's your favorite characters ah the
one that's always that I like pretends
like she doesn't even have down syndrome
oh he's talking about Megan yeah she
actually likes her DTF - she's like so
super thirsty yeah she's super thick no
I thought he was gonna make a move on me
and he did it he's like I went out there
and he actually showed me his movie
collection I'm like goddamn girl pants
are downstairs yeah I'm literally trying
to [ __ ] 24/7 yeah super thirsty is down
homeboy homeboy brought weather because
it he's like that [ __ ] that's a slot
yeah you so I'm not looking for that she
really put then Christina on that show
so it's a show about kids all down
syndrome the their lives how they want
to fit in with normal world and get
normal jobs and just their whole thing
is don't limit me yeah and so there's
this girl Christina on there and hurt
she has a fiance named angel and I
tweeted out last night I put at Amy
hashtag born this way what the [ __ ] does
angel have he doesn't have down syndrome
I was like does anyone know what
Christina's boyfriend Angel has I like
one person like [ __ ] you bro we no one
watches that show on the kid
point I guess I'm the only grown man
watching that show can't forget what he
has I went on forums like I was obsessed
with it trying for you really did you
look up his stuff yeah nothing doesn't
say when I say get everything all good
right and when it's not he's just
banging down syndrome girls maybe he was
normal maybe maybe he's normal and he's
just into that know they had his parents
on there because I forsake him like I
like this weird or yoshio weird dude and
so I brought brought up those days
parents are on the show like yeah we're
just hoping he can live on his own and
I'm like see that's not the way no
parents talk about he's 40
he's wait he's forty eight forty or some
now most of our a lot older than you
think like that man girl who acts all
extra like Hollywood has gray hair son
oh my god a black guy is like 40
something like 36 37 they're not young
oh man well now they get to run their
own coffee shop that's pretty cool
yeah where's that Lucas I'm excited for
that I want to go yeah I want to go to
mine Carolina
okay toes doing what's the call in 2002
my Derpy's what's a Cobb
der bidding you I get mmm starburns I'm
not going in on what's it called I would
love for one of them Biddy and both oh
it's called what yes
Biddy and bozos video why they even let
the kids name it I got nothing bro
oh yeah no yeah it's [ __ ] up yeah
don't limit them bro don't let him oh my
god just yeah I wish I got shot move on
for this one
Oh mather ste you imagine how often by
the way they get the orders wrong at
that coffee shop imagine so fresh it
somebody get the venti caramel macchiato
no nobody got that no I even ordered
that dim alright one more minute I'm
gonna make it right now that I doing
everybody's waiting is doin man this
place is packed no they're all just
waiting for drinks
oh you have been here since 7:00 a.m.
they're just 11 right now they're
waiting for you I'd rip the dress uh
what's this soon I got a I went to that
Biddy in Bo's like
I got a grande droop instead of a dress
but about the truth coffee mmm I'm not
down with this one associate I have a
latte more of these uh down signora
feature good
alright so this is a door around alright
another teacher who's pretty attractive
with a fuzzy features when I was coming
up I know man I'm telling you right when
t44 having sex with teenage that world
which is not to thirteen-year-old boy is
this this is most of her social media
pictures but they don't show that dude's
picture who see that mugshot yeah dirty
girl dirty yeah I already learned her
history tonight oh my god yeah this
stuff I would have done the one of these
teachers my teachers just like trolls
troll that I was doing and I and they
were mean to me too and I'd still get
like so hard in class well me too bad
kitties out a little bit oh my god I was
crazy I knew I was bored in high school
you're just a raging boner machine girls
man if one of these teachers was like
down to do that looking for one I read
about one a few days ago that was like
banging the kid in the car is this her
in the car this is car guy like and that
made it so no one in the clone that made
it given head and that made it like so
much hotter to me to suck his dick at
like lunchtime
I'm not really into like bed I mean bed
sex is like fun I know that's like what
everybody loves but there's something
about like cars their way or like an
office the bath you know there's like a
podcast studio you know season four of a
comedy senton nowadays yeah it's so like
the car thing made it so much hotter to
me I'm like guy you little dirty fine
extra you know how crazy what did she
teach gym she was teaching on let me
says here she was teaching kids how to
make coffee a Biddy Imboden
sucked up all the video poses employs
vidiian bones bullion is low
she'll also meant she had intercourse of
the teenage boy it wasn't that she went
to his home
that is risky it's like what the [ __ ] is
miss Anderson doing here yeah oh we have
to uh she's helping me with my uh oh
um yeah that's a tough explanation dude
again my teachers look like [ __ ]
Shrek I had nothing I got nothing
yeah does she what's her body looking
like your face looks different in every
picture yeah everybody it looks like
they took a bunch of old ones that mug
shot in helping to go buddy hovers her
chest up others is that her you know
when you're teaching can't be
blaspheming titties up looks like she
has a a couple a's herself that's a
small boob joke for a teacher Hayes
Hutchins jingo in full chingon full
catfish yeah
let's see well she looks like she has
has been body yeah she's way I don't
understand what's going on when I was in
tenth grade she could have had a horn
come on over forehead she made a pass at
me it was on oh yeah yeah Oh totally all
of my teachers were so scary
so so scary but I'm telling you man that
was a dream yeah I mean it-it's just a
dream I had a few substitute teachers
that sometimes would be like way way too
hot and they would know that they know
they like wouldn't have him on school
private school in Youngstown Ohio woman
called Ursuline all right named high
school is Ed O'Neill all right I've been
on the show this show
yeah show to Ed O'Neill waddell of
jiu-jitsu he still haven't met him yes
he is a boma coolest guys ever yeah he's
so cool that's what a real pro pro to
you know like this until forever a real
pro doesn't move fast I met her the
biggest legs I've ever seen legs knees
are like a dinosaurs really yeah that's
weird
he was a real football star yeah at my
high school gym player yeah Polk high
yeah Ursuline but Polk in the show yeah
and all that stuff was real like they
say like he really like did all that
like back in the day like he he was the
real deal and young yeah he talked about
the show he's like that you know really
really good ass
lead and then he got he found you know
some like playhouse for acting so I get
involved in that and it's fascinating
shipment he's killing the game still my
family's huge total hyena go from
married with children to Modern Family
just one of the other unbelievable
unbelievable so so such an amazing
career I mean you know he's ranked I
read a thing once where he's ranked only
behind Homer Simpson as all time
television dad got hit Bowl Bill Cosby
was up there until he [ __ ] the game up
but he ended up there yeah he was up
there no older from my crowd but I like
yet for me it's al bundy homer and then
[ __ ] Tim the Toolman to yeah I love
though that was fun back in the day
Daniel and Danny Tanner from Full House
yeah we're about the same age right I
think so holiday other before yeah 33
also died down maybe I'm just a year
away from crying when you hit 34 things
change but for you being on Netflix I've
been dreaming what's next brother let's
wrap it up man you got your tour where
you're literally all over the goddamn
world all over if you live anywhere in
America this is all different material
than my Netflix special this is my next
special that I'm going to be making I
really believe in and I've worked really
hard the last couple years on all this
stuff and it's coming together crazy fun
I'm really into it I'm going everywhere
I mean you know Charlotte holy of New
York every Boston everywhere everywhere
Detroit Louisville Nashville Ralphie may
is opening up for me in Nashville that's
the only date that Jeremiah Watkins
isn't going to be on so my boy Ralphie
Nashville zone there for that all over
everywhere Portland Aladdin theater San
Francisco Cobbs it all closes out at the
Comedy Store which is not going to be
easy for me to fill up at all since I
perform there all Vaughn yeah it so it's
an interesting thing that we're doing
with that'll be fun it'll be fun I got
to have a beef line I got to have some
friends on that one maybe I'll call you
in for that one
in September yeah and that's all
happening all those tickets are
available at Tony hunch quick calm or
monster outbreak something like that but
yeah just go to my website and get
tickets directly it'll be worth it
because we're having fun here - in the
week so I can vouch the first rate up in
is you know I've been doing comedy for
about two days now
so but you're obviously one of the best
comics in the world Wow Jeremiah walk in
the [ __ ] beasts and this is a guy I
think Rogan about anyone that knows
anything like Tommy I mean Tony's one of
the staples at the Comedy Store man
you're talking about a pro pro and I
mean I've been 1d clothes on this for a
while luckily not luckily countering a
cancer but it a spot open ah hey let's
just say I hope Brian's friend uh lasts
a little bit longer expect and I
wouldn't mind stepping into this exciter
in the pony man yeah the guy's the crier
in the kid at 20 huge global news ground
Twitter yeah this was so much fun thank
you so much Brandon and you're
absolutely killing it you know I've
talked with you personally about it but
I want your listeners to know like I
mean verbally since you hyped me up I
you know what you're doing it's the real
deal a lot of people try to you know
capitalize on their following and
they're in there and they're internet
thing and their podcast and they do it a
lazy way and you can you can fool them
once but it doesn't always blast and
you're actually putting in the real work
and in our last fighter to comedy
analogy of the day I'll say like you are
treating it like a camp you know your
training you're going to the hard spots
you're not taking it easy on yourself
and it is awesome to watch you do it the
proper way and it's you know it's cool
that you're part of our team and
everything because it's not an easy
thing that you're doing and it's live
streaming we all get to grow together
you know it almost brings a tear to my
eye to think about art almost I'm a
grown man
that's me a Chinese lady back namu I do
the Queen's in the airplane and get out
of here good rucks it was all this is
the fighter in the golden pony we're out
yeah great show
she threw coins at an airplane